For a limited time,
Postmates is hooking up our Watchers with $100 free delivery for a
week. Download the app, enter code KFC. Get a hundred dollars free delivery.
You're chilling at home. You're watching ATI. You're watching YouTube.
We've got Brian Callan on today.
You don't want to get dressed and go out and get your own food.
So get the app code KFC $100 free delivery for a
week. Anything you need anytime you need Postmates it.
Count. I'm about to answer the internet and guys good news.
My special complicated Abe says, Oh, screaming for free on Amazon.
And if you don't have Amazon, you know, buy it somewhere else.
Come see me at 10:00 PM, bro. June 20th, 21
[inaudible] who wins a fight. Tenure 10 ten-year-olds are 100,
100 year olds. Dude. That's a really good question.
Ten-year-olds 100%, especially if I'm coaching for them,
you know what I'm saying? I just had to go low,
take them out and then jump on their chest. Chest, chest your heart.
Can't take that yellow ticker. It'll take her.
Cause you got a bomb ticker to begin with. And then when you get in the CPR,
Ooh, a ten-year-old most ten-year-olds way, at least a hundred pounds.
Enjoy that. Grandma walking. I can ten-year-olds all day.
You had the flexibility to blow yourself. Would you? First of all,
I do have the flexibility. I'll drop into the splits right now. Naked.
You can see my three piece set. It looks like a dead baby bird. Ah,
what if everybody knew? Yeah. What if everybody knew you did, I'd be like this?
Cause I can give me the next pocket of bang.
You blow yourself. Aren't you a Christian.
Would you rather be the best looking dude in the world to be able to? Yes. Yes.
What's the next question. Or be able to read chicks minds.
I don't want to be, you know, I just, for me, it's,
it's very complicated up there. Like I have a daughter who's 10 or 11 now.
I don't know 20. I don't know. You know, I'm not into fatherhood.
It's all either way. She's a girl and I just don't, I can't figure her out.
I can't her brain.
I don't know if she can understand what she just starts crying.
I'm like what's going on. Sometimes girls like to hear themselves cry, you know,
I can't fix it.
So obviously I want to be the best I can do it in the world so I can get an STD,
take a pill. All right, thank God. Huh? For antibiotics guys,
you know what I'm saying?
What's one thing a person would say or do that makes you immediately hate them.
Oh God. Usually where they're like, you know, for me it's like,
I'm a very giving person or I've always been an overachiever
or I can wear these shoes all day and my feet don't hurt.
Well you and you're not in my inner circle and this is why China's killing us.
Okay. hate. When guys talking about their comfortable shoes,
Crocs, would you rather have two average kids or one kid who goes on to be a pro
athlete and one kid who never learns how to read?
That's fantastic feared. Well, nowadays you can listen to books on tape.
So who needs to read what is reading? That's so 2005.
So the answer is, um, I'd love to have a kid as a pro athlete.
Depending on what kind of sport it is. But yeah. Being in the stands,
tennis, you love tennis. I just, it's just,
I like being around the rich. I can't stand the common cattle, dibs,
disgusting beer, swelling, drones.
God, I can't believe everybody's allowed to vote there. I said it.
If you were gay for a day, who would you bang? You can pick whenever you,
I had a long conversation with well, probably Brennan shop,
but um, I don't know. He's got a great mouth. Um, I had a, um,
a long conversation with Tom cruise and he has a small face and I was so star
struck and I just wanted him to be my friend that I, I was like,
if that guy asked me to make out right now,
I probably wouldn't be able to say no, cause he's so famous. I'd be like,
okay, you know what I mean? And then I drank deeply of his millionaire mouth.
What'd you make of a Beaver's challenge who was in a fight Bieber, Tom cruise.
Well, I know that I bang Justin Bieber
cause that's a good looking young lady. I mean guy, whatever talented. Uh,
I got Tom cruise off day. Tom cruise was a wrestler,
a wrestling and Justin does some boxing, but good luck, Tom,
that force of will that guy's in better shape. He drinks bad blood.
He hangs upside down. Did you ever have,
would you rather have a three inch deck? No, no, no. Or only last 30 seconds.
30 seconds of a three inch stick.
He spent so much time with your tongue.
That's such man. Check ins. Right?
I got to walk around having a big Dick of it only last 30 seconds.
Let me show you, show you guys when I'm working. I heard rumors. Yeah, I do.
Well I heard, I heard you're heard you're a man hanging from a penis. Yeah,
I do. All right. I do. All right. Not going to kids yourself. I'll keep you.
I'll keep you happy and busy. All right. You know what I'm saying?
Clustering the bedsheets by the pillow.
Oh God. I'm sorry.
But is it there too? Who is the hottest celebrity?
He makes noise too. He's got lungs.
Who is the hottest celebrity that you think you'd have a shot with?
If they got to know you? Um, Margot, Robbie,
Margot. Robbie. Yeah, because I just, you know,
I like to do things like I just kind of like a drop Shay. I'm older.
I'm too old to be too forward, but I'm always like, I just, I don't know.
I'm just trying to find an old fashioned. I know you're not the girl from me,
but if I could find a girl that was into big comedy and money,
maybe you don't like the laughing come that hard. So I don't know.
See that's how she going to say no to that? Would you rather,
every time you come, it comes out of your,
out of your mouth or it's or it's a two liter bottles worth.
Ah, no, I throw up every time. Um,
two liters bottles worth. I just, it just be fun and be like, Hey, come on.
I'm about to make and rain. You're welcome. You know what I'm saying?
And I just, I just be in the orgy scene, lining up everybody, the world loses.
This is such a guy show the world either loses all women or all sports,
which you choose. I mean, yeah,
it has to be all sports guys. I don't want to live in a world.
We do sports for women's white guys. Fight bulls is why they going to war.
I mean, without women we'd be so lazy. We'd be,
we'd be shooting just here. Wouldn't matter. We just we'd be disgusting.
I don't, you know what I'm saying? We've never, we would never shower,
shame and just be disgusting. Women are important. They keep us on point.
I just want to say that I, I honor women.